the state by state battle over abortion
rights continued in indiana yesterday
protesters demonstrated at the state
house as lawmakers gathered to consider
a bill that would ban nearly all
abortions as nancy chen shows us the
implications go far beyond state lines
[Applause]
thousands of demonstrators gathered both
inside
and outside the indiana state house on
monday as members of the state's general
assembly met in a special session to
discuss a bill that would ban almost all
abortions except in cases of rape incest
or to protect the mother's life
the protesters were often so loud they
drowned out the debates inside the
chamber
i'm just sorry i didn't get all that
it's not a man's choice it's not the
government's choice it's not your
church's choice it's a woman's choice
vice president kamala harris was also in
indianapolis yesterday meeting with
state and local leaders about protecting
reproductive rights we are seeing indeed
many states
since the dobbs decision in attempting
even before
to criminalize health
professionals to punish women indiana is
in the spotlight as the first state
since the overturning of roe to hold a
special legislative session aimed at
further restricting abortion in just
last month a ten-year-old rape victim
made headlines after crossing state
lines from ohio to at the procedure
but without any new criminal penalties
against doctors performing an abortion
the bill's future could be in doubt as
some republicans argue the law would be
too weak indiana has this opportunity to
end abortion and we need to take
advantage it
and in abortion period for cbs mornings
i'm nicki chen